hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play outlast so
anyway we got finally got up to the
upper floors after being a giant idiot
for way too long I mean I'm a giant
idiot for a lot at the time but I was
there for way too long in that part like
seriously that all should have taken
probably about five minutes so anyway we
need to follow the upper levels in order
to get to father Martin who's just being
the biggest dick possible hi there how
are you doing he's being the biggest
a-hole possible getting away from me I
mean if he just waited up for like 10
minutes he would be here right next to
me but I'm assuming that he's forcing me
to go through these trials of some sort
in order to prove my worth - Wow no the
demon walrider god thing I have no idea
okay so stupid walrider son of a monkey
nutter okay alright then what's down
here what can I use ok battery's good
I've almost got full batteries oh I
there's a hole in the wall there's a
giant hole in the wall oh no there's not
I thought that was oh there's a giant
hole in the ceiling that's casting a
shadow to make it look like this giant
hole in the wall fool someone of a
simple mind such as me okay what am I
supposed to do how am I supposed to be
able to get back there am I supposed to
be able to get back there I'm not just
gonna be lost down here forever
probably that probably lost down your
throat um okay maybe I could push this
giant stack of beds no I'm up it oh yeah
whoa what did I just do nope nope nope
nope nope nope yep there we go alright
God nailed it
well that was a good exercise I'm glad I
did that so uh let's never do that again
alright alright okay
both hello any females around here in
the female ward no alright then see how
can I not remember where the cuts are
coming from they hurt so deeply even
days later dr. Newhouse tells me that's
my fault
I'm subconsciously resisting the
hypnotherapy but I want so much to get
better I don't know how I could be doing
this to myself
dr. Newhouse says it's another condition
of my bedroom inspired hysteria poor
Bruce I make him suffer so I've tried
subtly to ask mrs. Jackson if she's had
similar issues with her husband but she
is loath to talk about it her husband
too has found comfort in a younger woman
I know that doctors only mean well and
with the help of the government men
who've joined the staff I am in the best
hands possible I should just take my
pills and sleep and hope for a more
pleasant dreams tonight yeah it's
probably not a good idea and not gonna
help you in the least okay don't tell me
I'm the only one that thought that that
was a shadow pair of legs okay never
mind
hi mr. wall Radha how you doing what are
you doing on this fine evening no
batteries here that seemed to be using
my knife vision mode a lot more than I
have in the past matter here all right
like seriously that from the woods on
every Oh game of you ha ha ha don't be
doing that all right all right that's
the only way to go
the naked twins what it's a private eye
I don't naked guys oh you're so naked oh
you're so naked oh you're so naked I'm
just gonna hide in this corner probably
a very bad idea
but I'm gonna do it anyway cuz I'm a
rebel and I'm a shadow in the night oh
you are naked
where's the other one the other one
probably went down the other hallway
I hope don't be in front of me
oh don't be a brother they closed the
door behind him how polite of them ok
very gently not loud not smashing very
gently
I thought they slammed that door closed
because there was actually nothing back
there I didn't realize there'd be one of
the biggest threats of the game back
there ok now I don't know how to close
the door gently so I'm just gonna
meander in here without doing that such
as so as to not alert them to my
presence oh man I'm so pro right now I
am so pro right now they do not even
know that I am here I am way too bro
right now yeah one now but now you're
naked bastards oh crap what the hell I
made that are you joking me game you're
joking me you're yanking my chain
oh how do I get out oh this is bull oh
ok just get back here
well fine then if you're gonna be a son
of a [ __ ] like that
close that door get a nice running
started yeah there we go then I jumped
more who said that okay whatever is that
the priest I have no idea this games
being a little bit of a shine of a [ __ ]
I didn't even grab the ledge like I
usually do if I get close to something
okay you need to get a nice running
start No
[Music]
oh no oh no please tell me I go back
down there not through here in the dark
destroyed kid okay alright okay I gotta
go back down and get my camcorder good
think it got brighter all of a sudden
okay my camcorder went down there
someone came barreling through here I'm
just walking so nonchalantly la la la la
la la la la la who scared out of their
mind walks like this who does that no
one no one does that no one does that
okay alrighty then
so uh how far do I got a backtrack in
order to be able to get my camcorder I
might sound scary but la la la la la ok
I got batteries here but I mean what's
the point
I don't have a camcorder why did it make
the beep beep beep noise okay
things like so much different not
looking at them through the camera my
journalistic filter me Rupert Morden
himer is without my camera
where did my camera land that's the
question oh good it went all the way
down I couldn't possibly ask for a
better solution to my problems did it go
down here well I mean of course it went
down here but I mean in this particular
room I'm guessing someone took it
someone grabbed it and I've got to fight
them for it can i zoom in no can I have
night-vision no oh really oh really this
is how it's gonna be it's weird seeing
this gameand color oh hey you just
pulled right over me why don't you stop
being so crazy oh hi hi there how's it
what you looking at out there I haven't
seen any female patients yet maybe it's
just the men that lost it us have
simpler minds okay okay you know no
little piggy go home
where the heck did my camera go why why
is it behind a maze in a labyrinth of oh
he's at it over there
no come on really I just gotta follow
the light let me guess there's so many
people
oh it's cracked well I guess it makes
sense Oh broken Oh like I was about to
say like oh man that would have been a
great opportunity to have a whole closet
half guard just have a whole bunch of
people standing there huh not doing
anything all right whatever
ah way do I go up up up
clamber climb okay all right so my
camera got cracked but the least I have
it so now I can see in the darkness all
right that was good that was well done
yeah I don't know if it intentionally
made me think that Oh Mae oh there
weren't people in front of me but there
were why does it keep doing that at
random
I like that less I do it like that okay
find father Martin in the administration
block it was just in the female ward why
do I need to go the administra whatever
oh whatever
I'm gonna stop questioning where father
Martin is oh if I the guy in the
darkness I would have fallen to my death
it's good to know I'm spitting a lot
today camera why you be freaking out
like Slendy man's nearby don't
appreciate that you okay go drop down or
what get down Oh
Doki what what did you just do to me did
you signal to be are you a nice guy are
you one of those not psychos
all right by being nailed on the cross I
think what you shut up I'm not a patient
or maybe I am and that's the secret
twist ending don't know how that'd be
the case
considering I walked in here drove in
here rather oh boy little piggy no no
little piggy go home I'm no little piggy
you don't get me no I'm gonna say that
chant topic hammer seriously camera it's
only the lens it's broken right well
what was that was that a big guy who's
that the big guy that was the big guy
wasn't it oh it's so nice over here
it's almost normal isn't this where I
first came in why is the music all
dramatic
oh crap hey come at me bro come at me
bro okay good enclose that okay good
news just oh oh yeah oh yeah oh well now
your big ugly brute is that Wow
something's wrong with your head there
bro
something is something is sincerely
wrong with your head bro better look at
you enough [ __ ] around stop looking
at the dead body trying to get a good
thumbnail for the video the big guy is
apparently still chasing me because the
music is still kind of dramatic
okay and we're clear
nothing bad gonna happen here I keep
saying that I keep saying it's not true
he is soon me another interesting
conversation with Billie this morning he
says he's been talking to dr. Wernicke
again for a therapy in the white place
I'm disturbed by the fact that his
delusions have only gotten worse with
medication which isn't in the literature
for benzodiazepine diazepam in any case
his dead doctor friend is filling his
head with more German folklore
apparently the only thing that can kill
the walrider of vampiric butterflies
vomited from a demon called Horst key
the butterfly the butterflies suck a
breath from people's lips and drink the
blood from their nipples what they can
also take the form of a mass eiated
upright pigs or sick dog emoji burping
the show Billy's got that going for him
you'd mentioned Billy talking about his
mother's tattoos before are any of them
by chance tattoos of butterflies next
time I get outside of the Murkoff
firewall I'm gonna look online see if
there's a actual basis in German
folklore or if Billy's making this
garbage up from whole cloth would love
to compare notes sometime wouldn't mind
doing it over a glass of wine gets
lonely up here on 2mi Billy is that what
the thing is I've called other people
Billy throughout my entire gaming career
perhaps just perhaps I am Billy why is
my vision all like super shaky right now
my vision is like super super wonky okay
so apparently I wasn't supposed to go
this way other than for a note so I need
to go the way of the dead body push him
out the window so that I can clamber
over to where he is and then continue
into the room uninterrupted hello
oh there was another place for it go
down
maybe maybe not maybe baby there's one
more here hello friend something seems
to be wrong with your neck BuChE BuChE
you over no one will notice all the
patients will be like oh no dead body
fell from the ceiling I'm so scared oh
oh this is the beginning holy crap it is
oh my god it's weird to see it again
okay so Wow oh I need new batteries so
this is mirror to the place where little
piggy nono started where it all began
oh man so weird
that door is thoroughly bashed in I
don't think there's anything here for me
anyway oh wait this one file okay it's
reading rice Slater's Launer and dr. med
raagh I have pressing news concerning
the ongoing work of dr. Rudolf wernicki
and his development of the morphogenic
engine expanding on theories developed
in his brief but unfortunate
relationship with a Turing if I had not
witnessed it myself I would not believe
it had happened but beyond even the
promise of cellular regeneration and
guided cancer regeneration I believe
Wernicke's methods had breached the
spiritual realm something crossed from
the other side I personally witnessed
the appearance of an apparition briefly
but undeniably so please forward my note
and invitation to witness further
experiments - die die trick Eckhart
Eckhart I do not doubt that the Fuhrer
himself may need to be aware of our
discoveries it is my opinion that dr.
Wernicke successes represents an
enormous opportunity for our cause and
the German people and our obviously
sufficient reason to keep him out of any
sort of calling program regards to your
family
signature illegible man I didn't even
read the date on that
don't be freaking out randomly I
sincerely think that Slenderman is gonna
come up and poke me with his tentacles
okay so anyway what happened whoa whoa
whoa I went around the other side of the
door okay it's confused there for a
second but anyway I am back where it all
began and I am out of time for this part
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
that darn my bath
Wow
[Music]
holy still